la route pour arriver jusqu'à ce camping
situé au coeur de la forêt de
rambouillet n'a pas été longue
la plupart des vacanciers viennent d'île
de france et on choisit les yvelines
pour se dépayser
c'est un peu un hasard on
je suis ici avec cinq enfants mais qui
sont pas toutes et tous tes biens 1 et
ses enfants devaient aller à une colonie
de vacances en bord de la mer qui a été
annulé à cause du comité on voulait
faire des vacances un départ à pied donc
en fait là on a une semaine de vacances
départ de gifles fouet jusqu'à
rambouillet et on revient à gif donc
avec des étapes dans les gîtes campings
sur ce site 150 emplacements sont à
disposition pour recevoir des camping
cars ou des voyageurs entente et 75
hébergements atypiques sont proposés aux
vacanciers pour le moment depuis qu'on a
réouvert donc le 18 juin
on rencontre un public essentiellement
franciliens ils sont venus en masse dès
l'ouverture est là depuis une semaine on
revoit un peu une population étrangère
en recrudescence
pour ce couple d'australiens l'arrêt
dans la forêt de rambouillet était
primordial pour profiter de la nature
pendant leur voyage en france c'est
magnifique
toute la forêt c'est vraiment sympa et
on a emprunté beaucoup de sentiers pour
le vélo c'était très beau et bien
entretenus c'était agréable de sortir de
la route et d'aller en forêt pour
accueillir à nouveau les vacanciers le
camping a dû se plier à des règles
sanitaires strictes surtout pour leurs
piscines naturelles qui n'est pas
traitée au chlore et avec les protocoles
d'hygiène aussi inhérents c'est à dire
le gel hydroalcoolique avant d'entrer
dans l'espace piscine une petite
fermeture le midi pour pouvoir
désinfecter la plage puisque une piscine
naturelle ne se nettoie pas de manière
identique à une piscine chlorée pour ce
camping qui n'est pas encore complet les
réservations arrivent au compte gouttes
avec la crise sanitaire les français se
destine à partir près de chez eux
de quoi découvrir ou redécouvrir le
département des yvelines